after weeks of leftist mob violence
character assassination chaos and
lawlessness Election Day is finally upon
us you might not know that if you're one
of the countless conservatives who has
been banned from Twitter and Facebook
for posting jokes or articles or really
any other silly excuse that tickles the
big text censors fancy but if you were
listening to this show go out and vote
do it for Brett do it for your country
do it for the California deserts that
demand to be bathed in leftist tears if
you're a conservative a Republican or a
right-leaning independent go vote today
and if you're a Democrat do not forget
to go vote tomorrow
I'm Michael Nolan this is the Michael no
leo
[Music]
it's election day and you better be
looking good at the polls they've got
record high turnout being reported and
the one way that I can promise you that
you will look good is if you keep your
hair we got to thank keeps we got to
thank keeps because they can really help
you listen take it from me I am NOT an
Adonis of a man okay I'm perfectly man
enough to admit that I'm not a Hulk I'm
not a Hercules one thing I've always had
going for me though when talking to the
lovely ladies of this world is that I've
got a big poufy head of hair do you know
that a hair loss can start when you're
25 30 35 years old you can stop that you
can use clinically proven ways to stop
that for just a dollar a day we're less
than a dollar a day for just five
minutes barely anything but you got to
start now there are two clinically
proven medications that help you keep
your hair they're inexpensive they're
easy to get and keeps we'll get it to
you it's very easy to sign up takes less
than five minutes just answer a few
questions snap some photos a licensed
doctor remotely reviews your information
recommends the right treatment for you
all without you ever leaving your couch
it offers two versions of the only to
our generic versions rather the only two
fda-approved hair loss products out
there you might have tried them before
you've never gotten them this easy for
this price 10 to 35 bucks a month
anywhere from 33 cents a day to a dollar
a day and you'll get your first month
free quite a deal to help you keep your
hair no reason to put this off any
longer
stop hair loss today I'm telling you you
know when you lose your hair a
good-looking guy can really stop looking
great so do it
right now go to keeps calm / co' FFA co
v fe fe ke EP s dot-com / go FFA that's
a free month of treatment at ke EP s
dot-com / go FFA co v fe fe keeps here
today hair tomorrow and then you'll be
looking really good at the polls today I
have been told from my various sources
around the country that there is record
high turnout I wake up to a call from my
grandmother today in New York New York
doesn't usually get crazy turnout
because it's a one-party town and she
says she's never seen anything like it
in 50 60 years just hope people pouring
in to the polls who knows which side
they're for some of them looked like
they were shaved and had jobs and combed
their hair so we can assume that they're
going for Republic
and then others were screeching and had
purple hair and worse you know screaming
and Aramaic and Latin so we can assume
that they're voting for Democrats the
most important thing that you've got to
remember today on Election Day vote
Republican I know that doesn't sound
nice that sounds partisan but it's not
just about ideas you're right you're
right it's Election Day Election Day is
when we take ideas and we put them into
action there are two parties in this
country there are two parties the
Republican Party you know it's not that
it's always perfect it's not that it's
ever perfect it's not that the Democrat
Party is always evil or that it's the
worst thing ever in the history of the
world but there are two parties and two
ideas conservatives have a home in the
Republican Party leftists have a home in
the Democrat Party the parties have
become more polarized in recent years
this is largely a good thing a major
complaint in the 1930s and 40s among
political scientists was that the
parties were indistinguishable that they
it was the you couldn't tell which party
was which now you can if you support a
on any basic issue if you support law
and order you vote from Republicans if
you support open borders and undermining
immigration law you vote for Democrats
if you support jobs you vote for
Republicans if you support mobs you vote
for Democrats as the president has
driven home if you support our American
flag if you support the symbol of our
country you vote for Republicans if you
protest our American flag if you don't
like our American flag if you don't like
our country which that flag symbolizes
you vote for Democrats if you want
freedom you vote for Republicans if you
want socialist slavery taken over the
health care system you vote for
Democrats it's just that simple
we'd like to speak in ideas in
philosophy in ideologies and okay that's
very nice it's very nice to speak about
ideas purely idea that we can we can
bandy about ideas all day long but in a
representative democracy where you can
participate in your government those
ideas need to collapse into real actions
real behaviors real institutions real
political parties real candidates and
that happens on a day called election
day when you go and you vote that's what
you should do and and I have a Strad
if there are no Republicans to vote for
look I live in California I live in
la-la land where you know it's only
Democrats or communists or Democratic
communists I think those are the three
options we have out here so for certain
races they don't even have a Republican
or an independent running
they've only got a Democrat and a
socialist in that case right in Brett
Kavanaugh that's what you need to do
that's what I did voted we're gonna see
if there's a wave in California if
there's a Cavanaugh wave then Bret is
going to have to step down from the
Supreme Court and become the dog walker
in Pasadena or something like that
because I think that you've got to send
a message go out there don't give him an
inch we are winning you should not back
off and we're winning we'll see what
happens historically speaking Democrats
should take the house tonight and should
take it by a lot but my gut tells me
that might not happen the reason I bring
Cavanaugh the reason that I write in
Brett Kavanaugh and why I say you should
write in brick Avenel when there's not a
candidate that you want to vote for is
that the the Cavanaugh experience the
Cavanaugh nomination process tells you
every reason why you've got to vote for
Republicans right now because the
Democrats are lawless there were lynch
mobs going after this guy trying to ruin
his career undermine the constitutional
order undermine Edie duly elected
presidents right to appoint his own
judges and just this weekend Chuck
Grassley from the Senate Judiciary
Committee released the findings of an
investigation into all of those accusers
and it's about 400 pages long a little
more than that if you didn't read it I
can sum it up for you all the
accusations were bunk that's basically
what you need to know about it we'll get
into detail a little bit but that's what
you need to know bunk thorough bunk
conspiracies from Democrats from the
left from left-wing law firms people are
now being recommended for criminal
investigations because of their
participation in the disgusting slander
of red Cavanaugh that's what's on the
stick that's what's on the ballot the
people who did that smear against Brett
Kavanaugh they're the ones running for
office as Democrats right now you can
either vote for them or you can vote
against them so there's a new poll out
from Harvard which shows that the
majority of men and women think that
Democrats did not actually care about
women
during the Cavanaugh smear campaign of
court we knew this to be true I knew
that I knew Democrats don't care about
Christine Ford or Julie sweat Nick or
whatever happened in a broom closet in
1982
of course I think we all knew that but
what this poll shows is that it's the
majority of both American men and women
with the Democrats thought was that if
they if they went after Cavanaugh in
that way if they accused him of sex
crimes in the early 80s then even if
they didn't gain any votes among men
they would gain some votes among women
actually the opposite happened and this
is not a Republican Democrat thing this
is not a left-right thing the majority
of Americans men and women believe that
the Democrats were exploiting these
women acting politically acting
cynically that they didn't really care
about these women so a big takeaway from
this Grassley report no evidence to
substantiate any of the claims made
against Cavanaugh there is no evidence
any of the claims that means Christine
Ford any version of the story that she
presented that in 82 or 83 or 84 either
two or three or four guys attacked her
in a room that was next to her house or
20 minutes away from her house and this
was and she she was afraid of spaces and
then not afraid of closed spaces and
them afraid to fly and they're not
afraid to play any of the stories
whichever one you choose to believe put
it on a dartboard throw a dart at it
there is no evidence to substantiate
those claims no evidence to substantiate
the claims that Brett Kavanaugh whipped
it out at a party freshman here at Yale
no there was another one Debbie Ramirez
his allegation no evidence that Julie
sweat Nick or Michael avenatti had some
accusation against her at a credible
accusation against Brett Kavanaugh from
other parties around Georgetown Prep no
evidence about any of it so the the
Grassley report also shows the changing
storyline that Christine Ford had
storyline changed constantly we knew
that people who were paying attention
knew that I think people on the Left
people who didn't want an originalist
judge and the court tried to pretend
that the storyline wasn't changing but
it did a key aspect of this though is
that in her testimony Christine Ford
said that because of the alleged
in 82 or 84 whenever it was she
struggled academically she struggled
academically for four to six years
afterward had had trouble socializing
didn't have a lot of friends couldn't go
to parties couldn't get it I couldn't
get her work done in college this has
been contradicted by people who knew her
in high school in college one there's no
evidence that she struggled it all
afterward in high school none whatsoever
but so then she makes the claim about
college there was a classmate of hers
who said that she had a lot of friends
in college that she frequently went to
parties that she frequently went to frat
parties that she wasn't afraid of closed
spaces that she wasn't afraid of
drinking or chugging beers with the Bros
or whatever whatever they did in college
that she was doing all of that and that
she wasn't afraid to be in a room with
boys now do we believe this guy who's
tell who's saying that he saw her do all
these things during her freshman and
sophomore year of college I don't know I
have just as much a reason to believe
him as I have a reason to believe
Christine Ford another thing that came
out of the Grassley report two boys say
that they may have been either grown men
at the time they were boys said that
they may have been the person that
Christine Ford was talking about and not
Brett Kavanaugh so they don't describe
what she described but they describe
events that could be similar and could
be interpreted that way one of them said
that he a kiss happened uh in the
bedroom of a house which was about 15 to
20 minute walk from the van Ness metro
station which is about in the vicinity
that she describes that dr. Ford was
wearing a swimsuit under her clothing
and that the kissing ended when a friend
jumped on the bed as a joke now an
important distinction here is that
according to this friend she initiated
the kiss but a lot of similar details
here the friend jumping on the bed the
swimsuit the party does this mean that
Christine Ford is lying not necessarily
she could just get it mixed up people
mix up their memories all the time
especially when they're drinking
especially thirty years after the fact
another guy says that it could have been
him that she was talking about that he
made out with a girl that he thinks
could have been Christine forward at a
party around the same time around the
same place and both of these guys
apparently looked like Brett Kavanaugh
okay that's fine the Senate Judiciary
Committee asked Christine Ford's
to respond to this no response no
response at all because Christine Ford
said she wouldn't pursue the accusations
any further because why would she why
would they pursuit this was always about
preventing an originalist judge from
getting on the court and now that he got
on the court okay why would we don't
want any more attention on this this is
there's some inconsistencies being
pointed out in our story so we're gonna
back off a little bit another finding
from this report the media reported that
Leland Kaiser that was the lifelong
longtime best friend or a close friend
rather of Christine Ford that she said
she'd never met Brett Kavanaugh
according to media reports Leland Kaiser
then said she felt pressure from
Christine Ford and her attorneys to
change her story just just to not refute
Christine Ford even though she did
refute christine Ford because she said
that she never met Brett Kavanaugh
another another aspect of this we heard
famously
in all of this that Brett Kavanaugh
likes beer and he still likes beer and
do you like beer senator sometimes he
drank too much okay so we we know that
he likes beer but Christine Ford kept
saying I had one beer at the party and I
will just tell you something as a guy
who's been to a couple parties you know
went to college whenever somebody says I
had one beer they had more than one beer
that's it that is that's what it means
if you look up I had one beer in the
dictionary it means I had a lot of beer
he said what are you talking about
officer I just had one beer but seems to
be the officer problem that's it they
definitely add more than one beer and so
friends of Christine Ford said that she
would go to these parties a lot and
drink I'm not knocking her for it a lot
of people do that in college in high
school and and at the time I think the
drinking age was 18 or it had just been
changed so just pointing out an apparent
inconsistency so one of the accusations
against Cavanaugh is that he whipped it
out at a party in college his freshman
year it turns out that there was another
notorious flasher at Yale at the time
that Cavanaugh was there this is
according to classmates who were there
at the time so there was this notorious
flasher who was not Brett Kavanaugh and
as the classmate said if it were Brett
Kavanaugh trust me we would have known
the word would have gotten around but it
was not him and I think I pointed this
out at the time
when we were talking about Kavanagh that
Yale is a very naked school they just
there's a lot of streaking and there's
things like this it just it's a very
naked place I don't know what to tell
you but it appears that this was not red
Cavanaugh by the best evidence that we
have at our disposal so then this brings
us to Michael avenatti Busta Busta the
the former future president former
future Democrat nominee for president
Michael avenatti his client Julie sweat
Nick apparently this is the weirdest one
of all so there's good evidence now that
sweat Nick and avinasi criminally
conspired to make materially false
statements she is the one who said that
Kavanagh would host gang rape parties
and she saw him gang rape girls all the
time and for some reason she kept going
to these parties that part was never
explained he said why don't you tell
somebody why don't you call the cops now
I just kept going
I figured they'd get better for the
sixth or seventh gang rape party that
Brett Kavanaugh hosted so there's
they're now being investigated for
criminally conspiring to make materially
false statements Julie sweating it
Michael a vanadis client apparently
according to this report has a long
history of making sexual harassment
legal threats lawsuits claims and during
those threats and lawsuits and
accusations was represented by Deborah
Katz the same lawyer who represented
Christine Ford who was recommended to
Ford by Dianne Feinstein is the starting
to smell to anybody is this not it
doesn't smell very good does it
so that's quite a coincidence isn't it
quite a coincidence and then finally
there was a claim by an ex-boyfriend of
Christine Ford that
Christine Ford coached a friend of hers
on how to take a polygraph test and beat
it that friend was a former FBI agent
Monica McLean the Ford team denied it
apparently now Monica McLean is being
investigated for this claim they might
have changed some statements they might
be backing off that denial so it's
entirely possible that this ex-boyfriend
is right that Christine Ford did coach
Monica McLean on how to beat up
a graph test which means that she
perjured herself before the Senate
Judiciary Committee when she said she
never coached anybody on how to beat a
polygraph test she might seem to know a
lot about polygraph tests which makes
her volunteering to take a polygraph all
that more suspect add this to all of the
contradictions in her testimony but she
said it was she had to tell her whole
life story the polygraph test took
forever the polygraph test in reality
was two questions she volunteered to do
it she said she's afraid of flying she
flies all over God's green earth she
said that she got a second door on the
front of her house because she was so
afraid of being in enclosed spaces from
this assault she got the the second door
in the house years before the issue of a
sexual assault ever came up she said it
came up in 2012 when she talked about it
to her her marriage therapist actually
they put in the request to build the
door four years earlier so that she
could have a separate office and so that
they could rent out the room to Google
interns in college interns it all adds
up to no credibility whatsoever and this
is why you've got to do it for Brett
today you've got to go out Election Day
for Brett because all of this stuff was
treated as though it were gospel truth
this woman of unimpeachable integrity
how dare you point out that her story
doesn't add up how dare you point out
the contradictions how dare you question
Michael avenatti or Julie sweat Nick or
any of these other people it he has been
slandered as a rapist brick avan-ha his
family has been destroyed
he's been dragged through the mud all
for what to protect the the the
sacrament of abortion
the left's sacrament of abortion to
protect roe versus wade that's what it's
all about
and that it's so dirty how they played
and it's they're so full of it that I
really hope that we see conservative
voters reasonable independent voters go
out there and say no more this is too
much it's too despicable we're not gonna
let this happen
because if they are rewarded for this
kind of behavior you're only gonna see
more of it so you may have noticed that
I'm back on Twitter before I explain to
you how I got back on Twitter let me
tell you about software advice software
advice is when you're dealing with a
real head-scratcher you should have your
go-to person to call this is a
no-brainer
and it's why I got to tell you about it
software advice when you're working for
a small business or a start-up where
you're starting one yourself you you
need a lot of software just to get the
business off the ground and you probably
don't exactly know what you should be
looking for it can be extremely costly
if you make a mistake it obviously
wastes your time it wastes a lot of your
employees time and that's time that you
don't have when you're starting a
company right now get your own advisors
that will point you in the right
direction get you working more
efficiently right away go to software
advice comm slash Knowles Kano wles
how much does it cost it's absolutely
free don't say I never did nothing for
you you'll be connected with an advisor
to discuss the best software options for
your need it takes just 10 minutes or
less if you're a medical professional
construction manager HR pro you name it
software advice will save you time and
help you make a more informed decision
if you're an entrepreneur or work solo
software advice is a great way to get an
expert opinion even without the
resources of a big company go to
software advice comm slash Knowles to
get started in the software struggle
today software advice.com slash Knowles
nowl es connect to an advisor for free
software advice.com slash Knowles I'm
back on Twitter and well technically
maybe I'm not back on Twitter I you
might have C if you're following me on
Twitter at Michael J Knowles you'll see
that my new name on Twitter is
definitely not Michael Knowles because
I'm afraid I know that they're going to
kick me off again eventually the way
that I got back on Twitter is you know I
was kicked off basically because Donald
Jr retweeted a criticism that I had made
of CNN and it was so widely shared that
they kicked me off and they used as an
excuse a joke I made about the election
in which I said Democrats should vote on
Wednesday and so they said they removed
the post immediately and then they when
I tried to log into Twitter they had
that this screen and it said you can
appeal your suspension or you can remove
the post and waive your right to an
appeal so I said okay I'm going to
appeal it because actually in my post I
said make sure you vote in this poll on
whether Twitter should kick off
conservatives for joking so it even had
it wasn't even the joke that they
thought it was it was actually a
punchline
about Twitter censoring conservatives so
I said I'm gonna appeal it so I appealed
my suspension guess what I heard back
from I'll give you nothing I heard
nothing back and they wouldn't respond
and so it's an indefinite Twitter
suspension that I had and I really
didn't want to be off for election night
so they'd already removed the post and
what they want you to do is waive your
right to an appeal I'm not getting an
appeal anyway so I clicked it and they
reinstated me right away but I've talked
to a lot of my friends oh and Benjamin
was here yesterday it's only a matter of
time eventually they will kick me off
this is why I vigorously defended Alex
Jones when he was kicked off of Twitter
because but not because I watched the
Alex Jones Show he might be
conspiratorial he might be a shirtless
vitamin salesman he might think that the
freaking frogs are gay I don't know but
they kicked Alex Jones off to establish
the principle to kick off gavin McGinnis
or Owen Benjamin you know they kicked
off they got to kick off Alex Jones
because he's a conspiracy theorist then
they got to kick off Gavin and Owen and
other people because they're comedians
so they push things too far they say
things that are outrageous they say
things that are offensive that's their
job they're comedians so they kicked
them off and we say look well they did
see you know they said an offensive
thing well I shouldn't have done that
okay then they kicked those guys off to
kick me off that's why to kick me off
and how do they are they gonna get away
with kicking me off well because I don't
have I don't have the single
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the country I got like you know its top
three maybe but it's not not the
fastest-growing I'm sorry to say and so
they can kick off people who don't have
a million followers let's say they have
a hundred thousand followers or eighty
thousand followers or whatever they can
kick you and then they just bring it all
the way up and they're gonna start
heating it up and by the way since I got
kicked off of Twitter I've heard from a
lot of people who don't have check marks
who don't have 50,000 followers who have
been kicked off for nothing and you see
the post that they were suspended for it
has nothing to do with anything it has
nothing to do with the election just and
they they say you're suspended for three
days seven days ten days they're coming
for you they came for Jones we said
nothing they came for Gavin we said
nothing they came for me
I'm definitely not Michael Knowles now
I've got a mustache on Twitter some
people said nothing some people raised a
ruckus they're going to march on and
they're going to keep censoring
conservatives and the American people
know this by the way there's a Pew study
out that shows that 72% of Americans
believe that social media censors people
based on their political views
72% that's not just conservatives that's
not just Republicans that's the majority
of the vast majority of people a project
Veritas James o keeffe's organization
showed that Twitter was shadow banning
conservatives in just January of this
year a few other examples Google when
you google the California Republican
Party I think they've fixed it now but
when you google to be used to list their
ideology as Nazism oh that money it was
just a mistake though I'm sure it was
probably just a mistake
hmm who can you know just a whoops
whoopsie-daisy same thing with Google
when you would Google a a new North
Carolina State Senator a Republican
state senator the first photo that would
come up Coulter a bigoted label just big
it right across him and and we've seen
all of the bands so they suspended me
for not even telling the joke that they
thought I was telling they suspended
James Woods for making a joke they
suspended who you know Owen Gavin all of
these other people but on Facebook it's
not just Twitter conservative
commentators it's not just people who
have talk shows or political podcasts or
whatever on Facebook they banned major
Catholic pages so now we're moving
outside the realm of just American
conservatism there was one called Jesus
and Mary 1.7 million followers on
Facebook kicked off Catholic and proud
at six million followers on Facebook
kicked off what well there's a lot of
overlap between Catholicism and
conservative thought there's a lot of
overlap between the Christian internet
and conservative Internet I think they
might have reinstated one or both of
those pages but they kicked him off for
a while conservative activist grace
Johnston who's known as activist mommy
on social media she criticized Teen
Vogue for encouraging its readers young
teenagers
for encouraging them to have a very
creative sex in places that you
shouldn't have sex and you know it's a
family show I don't want to get too into
detail here for talking about things
that twelve-year-old shouldn't be
talking about thirteen-year-old
shouldn't be talking about she
criticized Teen Vogue she was then
kicked off of social media Marsha
Blackburn running in Tennessee she ran a
pro-life ad on twitter twitter said no
deleted the ad nixed the I'd kick tit
off Facebook now censored alveda King
Martin Luther King Jr's niece a censored
her for running an ad for a pro-life
movie that she was involved in a movie
about Roe vs. Wade
alveta King that's not Gavin McGinnis
that's not Alex Jones that's Martin
Luther King's niece who's a pro-life
activist Prager University obviously is
suing Google they've been kicked off of
Facebook for periods of time had their
mute their videos censor because they
talked about such controversial
outrageous topics as the 10 commandments
on YouTube they had a series on the 10
commandments censored you couldn't see
it at universities or at high schools so
just remember what you'll see this on
social media today on Facebook and on
Twitter the big headlines big headers it
says get out and vote don't forget to
vote here's your polling place go
register they're not talking to you
they're not trust me they're not talking
to you they're talking to left wingers
that they want to go and get out to vote
but they don't want you to get out and
vote in fact they don't even want you on
their platforms that's how you know that
they're not talking to you is they're
censoring you and they're kicking you
off right around an election and they're
deleting your facebook pages and they're
deleting your communities on there so
when they have these big campaigns get
out and vote go to your polling place
the question that this raises is is this
election interference if they are
providing material support to get
Democrat voters out there and vote and
if they are providing material support
to kicking off kicking conservatives off
of the platform blocking them from
seeing those resources
blocking them from getting their message
out is that election interference there
was a report that came in today that the
d-triple-c
Democratic Congressional Campaign
Committee has been pestering Twitter to
delete conservative accounts and the
Twitter has obliged not not sure if this
is true I wish that I could get more
verification before I report that but
Twitter never gives us verification on
anything because this is the central
problem of social media is these big
tech companies are totally opaque they
have no transparency at all so are they
providing material support to Democrats
are they providing in-kind contributions
to Democrats are they interfering in the
election and this is a question that
should involve the FEC because if they
are giving support to Democrats and
they're hurting Republicans in elections
they should have major election lawsuits
filed against them they should and they
should be regulated as political
entities or as political publishers or
whatever but not as open platforms that
is how the social media treat the GOP
how do the mainstream media treat the
GOP this is a little gift
this was a Christmas comes early
Election Day gift came in there's a guy
named John James he's running for Senate
and a reporter left you know he's a
Republican a reporter left him a
voicemail to try to get an interview
with John James and she thought that she
had to hung up her phone once you
finished the voicemail she hadn't so the
James campaign still had the rest of
this and she starts to give her opinion
to her colleague in the room well she
thinks that the Republican is not
listening here's the voicemail hi my
name is Brenda battle I am a reporter
with the Huron Daily Tribune and Bad Axe
Michigan looking to set up an
appointment with mr. James for some time
on Wednesday for a phone interview
regarding the election results if you'd
like to call me that my number is nine
eight nine thank you and he beats her
Jesus
so it's suck effing John James that
would side I don't think it's gonna
happen but I almost comical oh this God
like theatrical like she's on stage you
know it's like overwritten if you had
handed that that screenplay in in
Hollywood they'd say that's a little
overwritten it's a little overwrought I
don't know about that but that is what
you're dealing with nobody should be
surprised by that that's what reporters
are that's what journalists are sure
it's so-called journalists I don't mean
to smear all of them there are a handful
of good journalists but not very many in
this stage most of them are political
operatives for Democrats who despise the
Republicans that they're covering and
seek to undermine them every chance they
get we've got a lot more to get to
including the final argument moving into
the midterm elections and whether that
final argument is going to work from
President Trump from Rush Limbaugh and
from Abraham Lincoln but first I've got
to say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube
if you're on those places I'm amazed you
haven't been kicked off if you're unde a
Lee Weyer thank you you helped keep the
lights on in our Tora Bora cave over
here
you keep cough F a mic up tune in
tonight we are gonna be live starting at
5:00 p.m. Pacific 8:00 p.m. Eastern for
the daily wire backstage election
special god-king jeremy boring ben
shapiro Andrew flavin Alicia Krauss and
a little ol me we'll be covering all the
latest election news as it happens we
will even be getting Twitter updates
from our own Cassie Dylan and for some
reason Colton Haas I couldn't exactly
tell you I know it should be very good
we're very happy to have Cassie and
Colton both on in Alicia's corner to
give us election updates you're not
gonna want to miss it as always only
daily wire subscribers get to ask the
questions so make sure to subscribe
today also you know it's ten bucks a
month hundred dollars for an annual
membership you get me the Indra Clavin
show the ben shapiro show you get
another kingdom early and you get to
watch the whole thing you have to ask
questions and the mailbag you have
conversation you get a ton of stuff now
actually but this is what you get
the leftist here's tumblr now I'm aware
that some watching and listening to this
right now or watching and listening
before the midterm elections some are
listening after the
term elections I call this Schrodinger's
tumblr because it could simultaneously
be completely filled or completely empty
as both at the same time right now as we
are are wondering what way which way the
election is turning get your
Schrodinger's tumblr it immediately so
that you can either bathe yourself and
left us tears or fill it up with your
own tears
depending on other midterms ago go to
daily wire calm we'll be right back
so that's how the media treat
Republicans F and John James Bennett if
he wins that'll suck that's how they
treat Republicans how do they treat
Democrats Jorge Ramos talking to
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez take it away
Medicare for all is it for expensive no
people often say like how are you gonna
pay for it and I find the question so
puzzling because how do you pay for
something that's more affordable how do
you pay for cheaper rent how do you pay
for it you just pay for it and we're
paying more now it's not better that
we're saying this whole system is free
it's saying it is free of cost at the
point of service so that means that
you're not delaying going to the dentist
you're not because you don't have the
cash at the point of service what what
was any of that what did she so to begin
she said one thing which is true which
is that she finds the question puzzling
that is true I think Alexandria okay SEO
Cortes finds many questions puzzling
including this one then she says a bunch
of things that aren't true and or are
irrelevant so she said that we're paying
more now we're paying more now for
health care that isn't true right now
the federal government pays about one
and a half trillion dollars per year for
health care her proposal Medicare for
all at the lowest end for socialist
health care will cost three point two
trillion dollars per year that's more
than double that we would have to double
at least up we're actually more than
dumb annual tax receipts to the federal
government to pay for her program we're
not paying more now we're paying less
than half now we're paying way way way
less now and we have way more freedom in
our health care choices under her plan
that won't go away the problem by the
way she says the problem is that people
don't have money to pay at the point of
receiving the service at this point she
is just babbling that has nothing to do
with what she's talking about it has
nothing to do with the role of the
government in health care it has nothing
to do with premiums increasing or
decreasing we were told with Obamacare
that because the government was taking
over more of the health care system
premiums would decrease they didn't
decrease they dramatically
increased she's just spouting words and
it's it's a trick that Democrats do
which especially her Alexandria Ocasio
Cortes living blissfully and blithely in
ignorance which is that she says things
with total confidence other than that
time she said she's not the expert then
she when she gets called out on it by
conservatives like Margaret Hoover when
she gets close she says could you
explain your position on
israel-palestine she goes oh he he I
don't I'm not the expert but when she's
not called out on it she seems confident
so Jorge Ramos isn't gonna call her out
the mainstream media aren't gonna call
her out and say you know actually your
plan costs more than doubled the current
plan then she might have to say I'm not
the expert but what she's saying here is
she's just filibustering saying look
it's just like paying your rent you know
we'll just pay for it yes but how are
you gonna pay for it
well j't we're just gonna we're
Republicans are aren't gonna but we are
gonna so I'd say the difference in our
plans we're gonna we're they're gonna
where they're gonna gonna go to party
okay that's fine and no pushback
whatsoever no pushback at all of course
not that's what you're up against this
is why President Trump at his rallies
points to the mainstream media and he
says they're slime they're liars they're
fake news because they are fake notes a
woman who called up that Republican
Senate candidate and said ah f him I he
sucks I hope he doesn't win that's fake
news cuz she's not an objective news
reporter she's not an objective
journalist she's a partisan she's a
partisan operative Jorge Ramos isn't
real news he's fake news he's a partisan
operative who's trying to help
alexandria Ocasio Cortes and President
Trump is right to call it out that way
and I'd like to point out he's making
his final argument for the election he's
making his final point which i think is
a good final argument but before we get
to that argument I just want to point
out Donald Trump has given everybody
everything they wanted everybody not
just conservatives or Republicans
everybody he has given so right now
today we're seeing record high turnout
it was predicted that it would be a
higher than at any time in a midterm
since 1966 it might blow past 1966
record high turnout we how many years
have we heard we need to get people
motivated we need to get people involved
in her
civic society we need to get people
involved in debt it ended at Trump did
it record high turnout record high
engagement record high engagement on
issues how long have we heard we need
the Republicans unified Republicans are
unified
we need the Democrats unified the
Democrats are unified how about the
mainstream media they're getting exactly
what they want they're profitable for
the first time in a long time they're
making noodles of money CNN is only in
existence today because of Donald Trump
CNN would be a cardboard box on a
Facebook live stream if not Donald Trump
he is giving them noodles of money and
the flip side of that by the way is that
people are consuming much more news
I guess CNN because you know airports
consume some news I guess because they
artificially boost their numbers but
even among American viewers CNN is is
finally getting some ratings and the new
media are getting way better ratings
places like The Daily wire places people
like us online news websites all of
these sort of things or get are getting
a lot more traffic because people are
consuming the news isn't that what we
wanted haven't we been saying for
decades we wanted people to be engaged
with public issues it's a representative
democracy they need to be engaged with
issues now they're complaining because
people will complain about everything
but Trump gave them exactly what they
wanted about a strong economy we've been
complaining now for over a decade
that the economy lagged is the financial
crisis at the end of the Bush
administration and because of the
horrific recovery under Barack Obama the
non recovery recovery so what are we got
net what have we got now we've got the
strongest economy in recent history
record low joblessness relative peace
abroad we wanted peace abroad we're
getting peace abroad more and more every
day
and finally protection for workers and
profit for capital businesses are doing
very well and workers are doing very
well we never thought that between
should mean you've had for decades and
decades Democrats demagoguing on labor
saying we need to give more money to
labor unionized labor unionize public
workers and you've had Republicans
talking about just boosting GDP for ever
and ever and all that matters is gross
domestic product and capital and there
was always an image I think it's
largely unfair but there was always an
image of Republicans and conservatives
as being tone deaf to the demands of
labor and what have you got under Trump
you finally you have labor real wages
increasing and you have GDP bursting the
economy booming doing very very well
this is donald trump's final argument so
that's an amazing accomplishment in
itself by the way because he's
reconciled two major demands of both
sides of the political spectrum here
profits for labor profits for capital
and he's he's done it in a way that has
irked both sides but this is his final
argument his final argument today
published a piece I think in USA Today
he said vote for the GOP and continue
the jobs boom and that's different than
just saying the economic boom and this
is really important in places that have
lost a lot of jobs to anything to
globalization to increased immigration
to illegal immigration to changing
regular dynamism of the economy is jobs
because jobs are different than just
material prosperity those are different
mankind is made to work there's a great
book out now by Oren Cass a right-winger
you know his is on on the right which is
called the once and future worker and it
talks about the role of work Adam worked
in the garden work is more than just the
money you get paid for it
men need to work when men stop working
they shrivel away they need to stay
occupied they need to be productive they
need to work and I think the GOP has
been a little tone deaf on that and I
think that the Democratic Party has been
completely ignorant on economics but
this is the argument here we can get
real gains for workers people back to be
meaningfully employed not Obama employed
not partially employed underemployed
leaving the workforce but actually
employed so that we can be productive
because society is not just about
consumption it's also about production
production is what makes you feel
gratified in your work it's what makes
you feel dignified it's what you are
called to do it from the Garden of Eden
it creates stable families and stable
communities and ultimately a stable
economy and this is a major victory and
I hope that it's reward
at the ballot box today when asked if he
has any regrets president Trump was
quite honest he was uncharacteristically
candid may-maybe characteristically you
know he does though they call president
Trump's statements gaffes when really
he's just speaking candidly and honestly
here's President Trump on his regret to
Sinclair is there anything as you look
back at your first almost two years
think you regret that you wish on you
that you could just take back and redo
well there would be certain things I'm
not sure I want to reveal all of them
but I would say tone I would like to
have a much softer tone I feel to a
certain extent I have no choice but
maybe I do and maybe I could have been
softer from that standpoint good answer
and I and I also am ambivalent on
whether he could be softer or not I I've
gotten calls from older relatives of
mine who say you know I really like
Trump and I wish you weren't so mean all
the time so nasty
you know frowning that gonna cut him his
jib Mussolini look I wish he would smile
more he were a little softer
how can he be soft how can he be soft
would that it were so simple would that
he could be soft too but how can he be
soft when he's being assailed from all
sides like this when his Supreme Court
nominee is being smeared as a racist
racist rapist baselessly and every other
one of his supporters and he himself are
being smeared as racists how can he be
soft I wish he could be soft too I wish
we could get to a point in this country
again where people can be civilized even
if they're tough even if they're
hard-hitting even if they stand by their
ideas and advocate for their agendas
where they could be civilized and adult
about things and mature about things but
they can't right now because the
Democrats are behaving like children and
so he's behaving like the mean father
thing no but daddy but I want I want you
to raise taxes dad no he's got to be
mean he's got to be the tough father and
but it would be nice if in if after the
midterms if you know somehow history is
proven wrong tonight and the Republicans
managed to hold on to the house which
you know the historical
the odds are pretty low but we're in
pretty strange time so it's possible it
would be nice if the Democrats could
realize that the resistance isn't
working I mean that's why these midterms
matter a lot too is it would so deflate
the resistance it would so discourage
the resistance these hysterical little
children that maybe they would grow up
and then he could be and he could be a
genial fella but until then he probably
can't on this day in history before we
go Abraham Lincoln was elected president
in 1860 on this very day I hope this
bodes well for the GOP he was the first
first Republican president the GOP was
founded in 1854 it had its first
national convention in 1856 and it got
its first president in 1860 its first
GOP nominee its first presidential
nominee was James Freeman I think right
was it Freeman or Fremont Fremont I
think which I just love that free is in
the is in the name of the first
Republican presidential nominee Lincoln
got 40 percent of the popular vote and
he defeated the other candidates the
reason I bring this up a little history
of the GOP before we go today is because
you'll often hear historically
illiterate claims that the Republican
Party of the 19th century the Republican
Party of Lincoln is really the Democrat
Party of today you say well how did that
happen say oh they switched one day they
were you know they've all met mr.
Republican and mr. Democrat sat down at
a table and they agreed okay you were
gonna be this one now and you're gonna
be the other one and we're just gonna
switch just cuz just for no reason and
this is absurd now one of the arguments
is that if they switched because
Democrats embraced civil rights for
black people because they got one Civil
Rights Act in their entire history the
Democrat Party passed one Civil Rights
Act in 1964 but there have been many
civil rights acts and the people who
were educators today and political
activists want to pretend that there was
one the Republicans passed every other
Civil Rights Act they passed one in 1866
over the veto of Democrat President
Andrew Johnson they passed one in 1871
1875 1957 1960 in 1991 many
Civil Rights Acts six civil rights acts
by Republicans dating all the way up to
1991 won by Democrats ratified by
Democrat President 1964
another aspect that is long forgotten is
that the GOP was largely founded on
tariffs on economic protectionism
President Trump said earlier this year
or last year that tariffs built America
he's right they did build America
Avraham Lincoln said quote give us a
protective tariff and we will have the
greatest nation on earth
it was largely a protectionist party the
US was largely protectionist now why did
it change it started to change after the
1920s when the US economy became the
biggest economy in the world and it
certainly changed after the Second World
War when we were the superpower so I'm
I'm not making an argument for having
protective tariffs all over the place
that's not why I bring this up I bring
this up to point out that history is
complicated and that when that the the
left says that the parties switched or
when people on the right or the left
neo liberals or Neo conservatives they
say oh there is no problem with free
trade and there is no argument for
tariffs in any case whatsoever history
is more complicated than that
it's much more complicated than that and
what we see throughout the history of
the Republican Party they've changed
their mind on tariffs they've changed
their mind on various issues of the day
because political circumstances change
politics is not philosophy there is
political philosophy but politics is in
real time with real people in real
places that you're going to see today on
election day and so circumstances change
Ronald Reagan's approach to illegal
immigration was different in 1980 than
ours is today why is that well because
the circumstances are different there's
way more illegal immigration today there
is a much higher foreign-born percentage
of the population there are many people
flouting our immigration laws it poses
national security threats and you've got
a left which is insisting that we can't
assimilate anybody to the culture those
are different questions why was there so
much protectionism in the nineteenth
century but not in the 20th century
because the scale and character of the
US economy had changed
one thing that the GOP has stood for
though threat all of that is this
through line ordered liberty ordered
liberty and that's what you're seeing
here
it began in in the very beginnings of
the party in 1860 now it was an election
about ordered liberty about about
whether human beings have have dignity
and the right to govern themselves have
should have freedom for let for lack of
a better word and you're seeing you see
this constantly pop up throughout the
history of the Republican Party a
through-line threat it you're seeing
that argument today and I hope that we
go out there and we see a big victory
today but I guess we'll know later on
make sure you tune in at 8 o'clock
Eastern five o'clock Pacific will be
smoking cigars and hanging out with the
guys and hopefully having a very good
night either way we're gonna have a
funny night I'm sure but hopefully we
have a good night for the country and
I'll see you tomorrow in the meantime
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show see you soon
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
semia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018